we're told a factory makes toys that are
sold for ten dollars a piece the factory
has 40 workers and they each produce 25
toys a day
the factory is open five days a week
what is the total value of toys the
factory produces in a day
pause this video and see if you can
figure that out
all right so let's just think about a
day before i even look at this
information if i could figure out the
value
per toy
and then multiply that times
the number of toys
number of toys
produced
in
a day
then we would have the total value and
still see if they give us that
information well the value per toy they
say the toys are sold for 10 a piece so
we could write this this way 10
per toy and then they do tell us or they
give us the information that we need to
figure out how many are produced in a
day we have 40 workers and they each
produce 25 toys a day
so the amount that's produced in a day
is going to be 40
workers
times
25
toys
per worker
now i could say 25 toys per worker per
day and that makes the units a little
complicated or i could just realize that
this entire expression i'm creating is
talking about one day
so the total number of toys produced in
a day is going to be the product of
these things and we can see that the
units work out just to make sure that
we're getting in the right direction a
toy in the denominator cancels out with
the toys in the numerator workers when
you multiply this would be in the
numerator this in the denominator so
workers
workers cancel out and so i'm going to
be left with 10 times 40 times 25
dollars and i do want it written in
dollars and so this is going to be equal
to
10 times 40 is 400
and then 400 times 25 let's see that's
going to be 4 times 25 times 100 so
that's 100 times 100 which is 10
000 and then the units we're left with
is dollars
and now you might be saying wait we
didn't use all of the information and
that's true we didn't use the fact that
the factory is open five days a week we
didn't need to use that information that
would have been useful if they said what
is the total value of toys the factory
produces in a week then we would have
said their value per day is ten thousand
dollars and we could even write it this
way per day and then multiply that times
five
days
in a week and that would have given us
the total value of the production in a
week but that's not what they're asking
for so we don't need that other
information and so we don't have to go
to that step and so this was really just
extra information probably to distract
you a bit